d'ailleurs j'en viens maintenant à
lionel jospin qui hier soir était au
palais des sports à paris l écoute des
femmes son discours a pourtant été
perturbée par l'irruption à la tribune
deux militantes d'act up le poids que
nous fait donc déjà vite un bug fabrice
dujardin hier soir lionel jospin était
d'une certaine façon en famille il est
arrivé avec son et plus ils viennent
tous deux se sont assis à un rang
derrière la mère du premier ministre et
à quelques sièges de la soeur de lionel
jospin la romancière noëlle châtelet le
candidat socialiste au milieu des femmes
la manifestation était programmée de
longue date allemand imprévus en
revanche l'irruption de cinq militants
d'act-up venu à la tribune dénoncer la
mort de milliers de femmes africaines
impose du sida et l'inaction selon eux
du gouvernement jospin slogans
provocateurs à la puce avant que lionel
jospin de répondre lui-même elisabeth
guigou prg à son tour le micro on ne
peut pas laisser dire que lionel jospin
et raciste c'est pas possible
la soirée reprend son cours normal à
lionel jospin est donc venu parler aux
femmes
il leur promet plus d'égalité
professionnelle plus de détermination
dans la lutte contre les violences
conjugales et plus de parité en
politique jusqu'à la fonction suprême
présider autrement
idéalement ça serait de faire présider
ensemble dans l'esprit de parité un
homme et une femme comme ça n'est pas
possible on ne présidera finalement
vraiment autrement que quand une femme
en france
sa présidente bref lionel jospin voulu
séduire les lames hier soir comme tous
ses concurrents il sait qu'il ya plus
des lectrices et des lecteurs
à